te tapes était vraiment réduit aussi
parce que ce matin nous partons du
macumba pour lier cette marie passe
partout les toboggans et nous avons fut
une course très animée le dès le début
des hommes sont sortis avec des
échappées d'autres sont revenus après
ben en fin de course les derniers
kilomètres les échappés ont été
absorbées puis est bon mais les les
costauds du classement général salinas
et est attaqué il est parti avec
beaucoup grâce et ils ont gagné sur
cette marie mai il y aura ainsi dresseur
qui prétendant à la victoire finale n'a
pas perdu beaucoup de temps il me l'a
perdue que 30 secondes ce qui fait que
c'est de bon augure pour l'avenir
dans l'ensemble on constate que la
course est vraiment contrôlé par la
pilotine oui elle est écoutée par
la pilotine mais aussi ils ont
aussi aussi les infos de du club de
louis dominicaine et c'est pourquoi qui
sont venus aussi vite sur les échappés
comment voyez-vous l'étape de demain
qu'il faut dire que le début d'étape et
des traits d'une personne va donner
cette marée mais nous passons pas par le
gourmand et après l'augmentation du cos
est attendue de cautionner assez roulant
qui va permettre à des baroudeurs devra
aller chercher une victoire d'étape et
des états unis
comme ça on peut point de beaucoup de
minutes